If you could double the amount of leads,
email subscribers, or online sales that
you make without having to make more
content or spend more money on ads,
would you want to know how? That's what
I'm going to show you in this video
because everything that you create
online, videos, ads, articles, should
all lead to one thing, a landing page.
And if you can double the conversion
rate to that landing page, you can
double your leads without double the
work. By the way, I'm Alan Dragou. I've
spent 15 years in the marketing industry
working for Fortune 500 companies like
P&G. Three of those years, I was the
vice president of growth of one of the
fastest growing marketing companies in
the United States. And today, I'm a
full-time content creator and
copywriter. This is what I do all day
long. By the way, everything that I'm
going to show you in this video, the
landing page, the breakdown, the
template, is all going to be a link in
the description below for you to grab
absolutely free. But, we got a lot to
cover, so let's go ahead and dive in. On
my screen, I'm showing you a landing
page that I created for an email
marketing agency that I co-founded with
my good friend Ben Fitterman. Heads-up,
I'm no longer part of that agency. I'm a
full-time copywriter and content creator
as I mentioned. This is what I do now.
But, when we were doing this together,
this landing page converted cold traffic
at 11.7%
and it converted warm traffic at
industry standard benchmarks at around
2025, 2026 where we are now is
converting cold traffic landing pages at
around 5 to 6%, which means that this
landing page right here converted at
almost double that, which means we were
getting double the leads and email
subscribers without having to double the
traffic or create more content, exactly
how I said in the beginning. And what I
want to do for you is I want to break
down exactly why this page works so well
and give you a template formula and
structure for you to walk away and do
the same thing for your own courses,
service-based business, coaching,
digital products, lead magnets, whatever
it is cuz this can work in a million
different ways. Let's go through the
landing page and then I'll break out
each element. First thing that you'll
notice is there is no scrolling, okay? I
cannot scroll down. Everything you see
on this screen is above the fold. Above
the fold meaning being in a visual point
where anybody, mobile, desktop, iPad,
sees all of this in one screen. That is
incredibly crucial. I have tested really
long landing pages, medium length
landing pages, and just a straight-up
above the fold, and the above the fold
converts higher every single time. The
landing page says, "Free 7-day email
course reveals how subscription-based
brands cut churn and drive 30% of their
revenue using email and SMS, even if
you're not technical, haven't built
flows, and your list is collecting
dust." And then it's a picture of my
friend Ben, who again was my business
partner at the time, and some
screenshots from Klaviyo proving that we
knew what we were talking about, had an
email opt-in here, button says, "Send me
the course." And then right under it is
written by Ben and Allan, co-founders of
Drew San and Co. We've helped 7-9 figure
e-com brands 2-3 X their LTV, reduce
churn by 28% in 90 days all through
email and SMS. Now that you've seen this
landing page, you see the structure,
let's go ahead and break down the
structure. Now to break down the
structure, I've went ahead and created a
template walk-through that again, you
can get in the link in the description
below, to give you an exact step-by-step
framework of what copywriting and sales
psychology I've injected into this
landing page for you to walk away and do
the same for your landing page. So,
we're going to break each one of those
down starting with free 7-day email
course reveals. All right. In the first
eyebrow copy up at the very top, you
want to reveal exactly what your person,
your reader, is going to get by being on
this page. It could say, "Free 7-day
email course, free 83-page report, free
AI tool, free guide." It doesn't even
have to be free. It just has to be very
clear. What is the exact thing that I'm
going to get on this page? And then, now
we're going to move into the headline,
which breaks out four unique things that
make it so strong. Okay, the four unique
things are audience, problem, desire,
mechanism. Let's break down how this
headline hits all four of those in one
swoop. Okay? How subscription-based
brands. This is the audience. This is
who we are targeting. We are targeting
subscription-based brands. So, when they
see that and they say, "Oh, yeah, I sell
supplements or I sell meat products or
whatever and it's on a subscription."
They know that is them. Cut churn. That
is a problem. Okay? How this audience
can cut this problem and then drive 30%
of their revenue. That is a promise. All
right? So, now we have the audience, the
problem we are solving, the promise we
are making, and then using email and SMS
is the mechanism that we use to solve
that problem for that audience and
achieve that promise for that audience.
All that in one line. So, we're talking
audience, problem, desire, mechanism.
One headline that's after they get the
clarity and then right under it is what
I would call the constraint section.
This is your deck copy. And in your deck
copy, we want to overcome the objections
because chances are people have heard
stuff like this before. They're like,
"Ah, yeah, cut churn, drive 30%. Well,
I've tried it." And things that they're
going to say in their head. They're
going to say things like, "I'm not
technical or I don't know how to build
flows and my list is collecting dust
like email, SMS you know, I haven't
emailed them in years." Blah, blah,
blah. I don't know why everybody's
redneck when I'm thinking about this.
You have to pre-answer the obstacles for
people. Even if you're not technical,
haven't built flows, and your email list
is collecting dust. All right? So,
you're pre-answering those obstacles.
Then, you walk down to the big image
section. I like to think of this in two
ways. Okay? If this is an image,
sometimes I use a product image. Like if
I'm giving away a a mini course or a
mini webinar or something like that,
I'll typically have the actual product
and maybe my face right next to it. So,
it looks like it's a product giveaway.
In this case, this was a pretty big
claim that we're going to be able to
drive 30% of your revenue and cut churn.
So, what I like to do is I like to put
some personality behind it with a
side-by-side photo and then some
screenshots of proof. The big one here
being proof. If you can inject proof
into the image, it will convert higher.
One other way that you could do this if
you don't want to do the image and you
want to go next level is you can inject
a VSL here and in that VSL, it's you
personally talking or whoever's
personally talking and you can inject
the proof in the actual VSL itself. The
next part of this framework is the
actual email itself. So, there are three
ways to kind of think about this. Well,
three layers to what you're asking for.
You can ask just for the email, which
will get you the most opt-ins. You can
ask for the name and email, which will
qualify your buyer a little bit more,
but you'll get a little bit less
opt-ins. Every question that you ask
decreases the amount of opt-ins you get,
but it increases the quality of the
person because the more information
they're willing to give you, the higher
quality that person is likely to be. And
then you can so much as go as asking for
an email, a name, and a phone number.
Now, if you start asking for a phone
number, your opt-ins will dramatically
drop, but you'll get higher quality
leads. In fact, much higher quality
leads. So, if you're selling a
high-ticket coaching service or a
done-for-you high-ticket service, a lot
of times asking for that phone number,
that name, that email all together will
get you the best buyers. It may not
double your conversion rate, but if
you're sitting at industry standard
conversion rate, but with significantly
better buyers, that may double your
revenue, double your income, which may
be worth it for you. The next thing is
the actual button itself. Don't say sign
up or yes, please or anything like that.
This is the part where I really like to
focus on action. Now, this goes against
a lot of what gurus do on their landing
page where they usually do like a
benefit. They may use a button action
that's like increase my revenue by 30%
or cut my churn or whatever, and that's
the button action. I don't like to do
benefit as the button action because it
smells like bull.
Right? You see that and you're like, all
right, dude. Like, come on. It increases
the skepticism, so I don't like to do
that. I've already got it in the
headline. I've got the proof. What I
like to do is make it really clear what
the action is going to do for them. Not
the benefit, but the actual action. That
when they click the button, I'm going to
send them the email course. So, it says
right here, "Send me the email course."
Very simple, very clear, but it's also
not this big skeptical promise that's
like, all right, come on, man. Like, I
that reeks. And then the last part is
the proof. I love to get the proof under
the button, something that they can see.
Now, I've got it written by Ben and
Allen, co-founders, which when you put
co-founders of an of an agency, that's
some proof. We've helped seven-to-nine
figure e-com brands, proof. Two-to-three
XL, uh their uh their LTV, proof. We've
reduced churn by 28% in 90 days, proof.
Okay? So, lots of proof element. You
could do things like 4,000 downloads or
five-star ratings, or you could put a
really high-leverage testimonial that
your target audience would really know
who that is. They would resonate. Be
like, oh man, this guy's worked with
Russell Brunson or whomever is very
famous in your industry. So, you could
do those sorts of things. That is a
simple walk-through, very easy, of this
landing page that converts incredibly
well. Again, you can go in the link in
the description below, grab everything
that you need, including the Carrd
template. I built this landing page on a
website called Carrd, c a r r d. I'm not
affiliated by any means, and it's
really, really simple. So, I come in
here and it's easy to use. You could
just come in here, change the
typography, change the headlines,
whatever. And the template down here
below, you could duplicate, swap the
photo. Okay, you can hit change photo,
whatever it is that you want to do,
change the headline, change the words.
It is your template for free. Get it
live on Carrd. You hit done, you save
it, you hit publish, and bam, it's live
on a landing page. You view the site,
bada bing bada boom, they put their
email in, you can connect it to your
kit. It's super easy. I've been using
card for year I need to get an affiliate
link for that. But that's it. That's the
whole landing page. It's really simple,
it's really easy to use, and I guarantee
it will increase your conversion rate if
you're not already doing something like
this. And if you found this video
helpful, it'd mean a lot if you like the
video and subscribe to the channel. It
tells me you want me to make more
content like this. If you have any
questions, you can drop it in the
comments. I'll be hanging out drinking
this fresh pour over that I made this
morning. God, this is good. That's what
you guys are doing. You're feeding my
espresso and pour over addiction. Every
time you subscribe to my channel, it
just makes me go
new subscriber. I get it. I get a
notification on my phone. I'm like, "Oh
my gosh, a new subscriber. Shots, shots,
shots." Can you imagine if I took an
espresso shot every single time that I
got a new subscriber? All right, enough
dilly dally. Let's wrap this video up.
Go binge more of my videos. Go learn
copywriting. Go learn sales persuasions.
Go build your email list. Go build your
personal brand. But for God's sakes,
don't work at a 9-to-5 job. Don't work
at a company. Build your own crap. Enjoy
your life and drink more coffee.